now this is just perfect in so many ways
I know that I'm always pointing out you
know crazy stuff the left is doing and
saying well see this shows where we are
as a society but that's my impression of
myself this is where we are as a society
that's Matt Walsh as Matt Walsh but this
really does show you this is amazing the
president of Planned Parenthood Leanna
when was ousted from her job yesterday
fired aborted after only 10 months
terminated though thankfully she was
terminated in a safe and legal
environment I'm sure she could take some
solace and that you wouldn't want to
have any back-alley firings you know you
wouldn't want to fire someone you'll be
fired
you want to be fired in in an office and
a clean safe place rather than in a back
alley but and certainly rather than with
a coat hanger but she's she's gone and
honestly I couldn't be happier that she
lost her job I think it's a wonderful
thing that she lost her job well
deserved and it's also best for her I
think it's best that she lose that job
maybe try to recover whatever is left of
her soul but listen to the reason she
was fired
a reporter M O'Connor reports that when
was given the boot because she's not
extreme enough or aggressive enough
she's not radical enough I mean this is
a woman who was willing and eager to
take on a job did take on a job at
Planned Parenthood where she's
overseeing the butchery of 300,000
children a year anyone who's willing to
do that anyone who wants to do that who
would have to be a radical extremist
militant abortion fanatic and and she is
but not enough for for Planned
Parenthood apparently and O'Connor
reported this last night here's one
issue where they apparently differed
says two sources told us that when also
refused to use trans-inclusive language
for example saying people instead of
women telling staff that she believes
talking about transgender issues would
isolate people in the Midwest
I mean my god they really got rid of her
because she wouldn't renounce her belief
in biology her well her partial partial
belief in biology she already would have
told you that unborn children aren't
people so that's so she already rejected
partially biology but whatever was left
of her belief in science had to go out
the window and she wasn't willing to do
that so they got rid of her
modern leftism is truly an insane cult
it is utterly insane the doctrines it
requires you to believe are just
maniacal and we'll talk more about
pregnant men in a few minutes actually
but I just wanted to bring this to your
attention because it's it's incredible
and it proves yet again something I've
been talking about for months the victim
hierarchy on the left the LGBT cabal
reigns supreme
they take priority all of their demands
must be met no matter what without
exception whatever they want they get
whatever they say goes
they are the uber victims they are the
the the head honchos in terms of
victimization so much so that among a
minority woman can be fired from her job
for refusing to pay homage to men who
dress like women it is remarkable that
in my know if the LGBT folks tell you
that you have to renounce science
science is evil science is bad you're
not allowed to talk about science if the
LGBT folks tell you that it doesn't
matter if you're a minority woman if you
refuse you're getting kicked out all
right so I wanted to tell you about that
as I said we'll get back to pregnant men
in a minute but before we do
representative Ayanna Presley is sort of
the Ringo Starr of the squad the squad
that consists of a OC and Omar and Talib
the ones that have been feuding with
President Trump well and with Nancy
Pelosi and with everybody else
Ayanna Presley
kind of she's the yeah the ringo star
the the joey fatone
if you will of the squad kind of well
maybe that's not fair to joey fatone I
think Joey Fatone was now he was you
know he had personality and I think he
was a lot of people's maybe second
favorite NSYNC member so I think Ayanna
Presley is more she she's nobody's
favorite squad member you kind of forget
that she's there so she's more who's the
the other NSYNC guy with the goatee that
nobody knew who he was or no one
remembers him no one knew what it was it
was what his function was anyway so
she's kind of that but they've all been
in spasms of outrage over president
Trump's stupid tweet that we've talked
about but as they as they continue to
express their outrage we have to bear in
mind that when it comes to denouncing
bigotry none of these four women have a
leg to stand on especially Presley who
now owns what I believe is one of the
most outrageously bigoted statements
that we have heard from him from an
American politician in several decades
speaking at a Joe Biden said yesterday
that President Trump said the most
racist thing that any president has ever
said which of course is completely
insane and I pointed out at least one
extremely racist thing that a president
said that was certainly way worse than
any tweet that president Trump has sent
but this really is and I'm not saying
this is the most racist thing the most
racist thing any politician has ever
said in America but it is one of the
most bigoted in the last few decades at
least speaking at a progressive
political convention a few days ago
Presley launched into a diatribe that if
she belonged to a different political
party or a different race or certainly
both it would end her career but instead
given her political party and her race
it and her gender to doesn't hurt it it
prompted exuberant applause from the
audience but it is so extraordinarily
bigoted I want you to watch this yes I
do quote shirley Chisholm a lot who said
if they don't give you C to the table
bring your own folding chair but I've
amended that
because I don't want to bring a chair to
an old table this is the time to shake
the table this is the time to redefine
of that table because if you're going to
come to this table and for all of you
that have aspirations of running for
office for whatever lived experience an
identity that you represent if you are
not prepared to come to that table and
so represent that voice don't come
because we don't need any more Brown
faces that don't want to be a brown
voice we don't need black faces but
don't want to be a black voice we don't
even list them that don't want to be a
Muslim voice
we don't need queers that don't want to
be a queer voice and if you're worried
about being marginalized and stereotyped
please don't even show up because we
need you to represent that voice the
midterm election of 2018 they spoke a
lot about each of our magic I would
never give sure it's shrift to any of
our magic but this is work and we put it
in every day now someone who is not well
acquainted with liberal speak may be
more confused than horrified by those
comments because you think well what is
a brown voice what is a what is a black
voice what is a do voices have colors
what you mean Brown black voice what she
means of course is that a brown or black
person should have the opinions that are
properly representative of their racial
communities and what she means by
properly representative of their racial
communities is that their opinion should
be resoundingly leftist so put more
simply Presley is telling brown black
Muslim and gay people to keep their trap
shut if they aren't going to conform to
her ideological expectations you're not
needed she says you're not needed I mean
that's worse than saying keep your trap
shut you're not needed we don't need you
are just an unneeded person your your
whole existence your certainly your
opinions are we don't need them shut up
that's such a it's such a demeaning
thing to say and she is making these
statements of
out on on racial and ethnic lines so
leftist like Presley feel perfectly
entitled to issue these directives
authoritative Lee sort of instructing
the plebs as to what they may or may not
say and what they may may not think
based on the demographic and identity
groups to which they belong her talk of
brown voices is pretty telling because
she doesn't see brown Black Muslim quote
queer people as distinct individuals
with their own voices than their own
perspectives and opinions she sees them
as monoliths these groups are monoliths
and every member of the group is a
mindless faceless representative of the
whole and the whole presley has decided
must vote Democrat must support things
like abortion affirmative action
universal health care must affirm every
last leftist doctrine without exception
and if they don't if they fall outside
of the ideological box that Presley has
created they are anathema at best
they're useless at worst they are they
are heretics who should be burned at the
stake or bludgeoned to death with a
crowbar as is an tifa's preferred method
now this is way worse than just your
sort of simple-minded run-of-the-mill
bigotry because the run-of-the-mill
bigot will will feel that his race or or
ethnic group is superior to others he's
going to be sort of tribalistic
and and and have this feeling of
superiority that's that is your average
everyday bigotry and it is a stupid and
harmful view to be sure to be bigoted in
that way as stupid and harmful but it's
child's play compared to the sort of
bigotry that Presley is promoting here
she wants to erase the individual and
live in a world consisting only of these
homogenous amorphic identities where
every person is but a mere mouthpiece
for an ethnic hive mind it is it is a
bigotry far more insidious insidious far
more horrifying than the kind of bigotry
that she constantly and off
fallaciously seems to find in the hearts
of other people it is it is I I cannot
even put into words how gross how
degrading how demeaning this is that she
would sit there and say like if you if
you are in this identity if you are this
race or this ethnicity here are the
opinions you're allowed to have
otherwise we don't need you by the way
do you think imagine if a Republican
ever made a statement that began with
the phrase we don't need queers that's
what she just said
we don't need queers and then but now
she qualified it and she explained what
sort of quote-unquote queers we don't
need but it doesn't matter be this
there's no way to end that statement
that is going to make it non bigoted and
do you think there's any way a
Republican could ever say that it
doesn't matter how they end it doesn't
matter what they say next you make that
you're done you're finished forever if
you say but she as a liberal Democrat
can actually say that she can actually
get up there and say so you can say
really like well here are the kinds of
quote-unquote queers we need and if
you're not in that we don't need you get
out it's something it's amazing and she
gets away with it
nobody even on the Left they don't even
think to have a problem with it oh my oh
my goodness it goes without saying if
Donald Trump were ever to say anything
like that to start to explain like
listen if you're a black person and
you're not conservative we don't need
you get out this year night we don't
need you at the table can you get even
can you imagine him what would happen if
he said that yet again if you're on the
left you can say stuff like that all the
time and nobody bats an eye it's it's
alright so let's go
two men having babies shall we a radical
left-wing doctor named Eugene GU tweeted
a few days ago and he was explaining
well I'll read what he what he tweeted
he said it is a scientific and medical
fact that men can get pregnant and also
have abortions trans men and non-binary
individuals are human beings who deserve
to be acknowledged by society they
choose their own identity not me not you
not any doctor and certainly not any
politician well of course I agree that
that I don't choose their identity
doctors and politicians don't either
biology chooses their identity that's
that's nature chooses it but he says a
scientific and medical fact okay this is
a doctor saying it is a scientific and
medical fact that men can have babies
well if you've listened to this show for
a while you know that I've argued that
the entire case for transgenderism can
be defeated completely debunked of
course it can be debunked in any number
of ways because it's just without a
scientific basis whatsoever but you can
easily defeat it easily debunk it you
can easily shut down anyone who begins
to justify it or argue for it
and you can shut it down not by shouting
at them not by insulting them but really
by asking them a question a very fair
very necessary elementary fundamental
question all you have to do is ask them
very simply what is a man or of course
alternatively what is a woman either one
will do in this case he says two men can
have babies what is a man extremely fair
question so I've been asking this
question of leftist for months and not
one not a single one has been able to
provide anything close to a definition I
put it out on there on Twitter I've said
it on the show I've written an article
saying listen if your leftist you
believe that transgenderism is a is a
legitimate thing this is it just just
what
what's a what's a man what's a woman
just give me a definition that's all I'm
asking for and so far not a single one
has been able to provide a definition so
I decided to try this again and lest
anyone accuse me of only picking on the
dumbest common denominators on the left
I decided to go toe-to-toe here with a
doctor this is a doctor he's a surgeon
he he he obviously holds some rather
let's say eccentric views but he did go
to medical school and I he certainly
knows more about medicine than I do
let's hope he's a surgeon
so I said I'll throw this if anyone can
answer if anyone in that camp who
believes in this stuff
if anyone can answer it and you know
really shut me down and and and then
this should be the guy right so I
tweeted him in response I said is what I
said a doctor what is a man please
provide a definition thank you
he responded to me credit to him at
least for responding and he said some
define a man as a person who was
genetically male with a Y chromosome but
some intersex individuals with a Y
chromosome can have female sexual
characteristics and even give birth some
say a man is anyone who identifies as a
man regardless of female sexual
characteristics so that was his first
attempt at an answer but that's not an
answer he's not giving me a definition
so it's already concerning here that
this is a doctor and I said what is a
man and he couldn't just give me a
straightforward answer should be think
he should be the easiest thing for him
to answer as a doctor or just as it as a
literate adult mike-mike six-year-old
could answer that question what he just
said there is not an answer he's just
telling me what some people say okay if
you if you look up at the definition of
a word in the dictionary the definition
is not going to begin with some people
think or some people say it doesn't
matter what people say what's the
definition so the first definition the
first potential definition he mentions
is of course correct but that's
his definition he's just acknowledging
that that definition exists yet that's
not the one that he goes with he has
specifically rejected and denounced that
definition in his original tweet he said
that men can add baby so the first
definition he mentions that's not his
the second definition he mentions is not
a definition at all okay and
you know a man it was a man is anyone
who identifies as a man well that's not
a definition you can't use the word
you're defining in the definition you
can't do that that's what is a classic
fallacy there you cannot do that doesn't
what's that circular if I ask you a
definition of an apple you can't say an
apple is an apple I mean an apple is an
apple of course but that's not a
definition that's just this is a
circular statement so I tried again and
I asked what is the thing they are
identifying as you say a man a man is
anyone identifies as a man okay well
what what is that though yes they're
identifying as a man what is that thing
and I said don't just say man again you
have to tell me what a man actually is
or do you not know he responds I define
a man as anyone who identifies as a man
gender is a social construct and even
though humans are sexually dimorphic
species in a in a bimodal distribution
biological sex does exist on a spectrum
with intersex individuals who are one
point seven percent of the population in
between this again is not a definition
it's like that it's like defining circle
as anything that looks like a circle
which of course is wrong because you're
using circle in the definition it's a
circular definition of circle and also
it's possible for something to look like
a circle without actually being one okay
your eyes can deceive you depending on
what the angle you're looking at it's
possible you think something is a circle
you get you get a closer look it's not a
circle it's an oval or it's a you know
it's the or it's just it's a an uneven
sort of circle like object but not a
circle so I responded him I said you
still haven't told me what a man is
you've just told me that anyone who says
they are one is one which is absurd of
course but also it's not a definition
when someone identifies as a man what
are they identifying as what is a man
you haven't defined it yet so we go back
and forth a few more times I'm not gonna
read all of them he keeps he keeps
insisting that he gave me a definition
and and I tried to explain over and over
again that his definition is obviously
circular and tautological and therefore
invalid finally he offers this and this
is his last word on this
the last thing he says this is the
closest thing to a definition that he
gives me again to remind you this is a
doctor okay he says you want me or said
he says you want to define a man as a
human with a y-chromosome external
external male genitals male gonads that
produce sperm has more testosterone than
estrogen and does not have any female
reproductive structures I say a man is
anyone who identifies that way including
trans and intersex and that's it he
doesn't respond anymore
that's his definition as a doctor so
let's delve into this a bit here a man
is a human with a Y chromosome external
male genitals male gonads that produce
sperm and does not have any female
reproductive structures yes
good exactly that part yes it's exactly
what a man is yeah that's a man okay
that's a man baby you got it
but then he says he throws all that away
because then he says or anyone who
identifies that way wait a second what
now and see this is really interesting
because normally leftist would say that
identifying as a man or a woman they
talk about identifying some as a war or
or woman they don't usually want to
explain what that actually means they
just say it's like what do you mean
identify is that what does that mean
explain to me what that means it does
not have a self-evident meaning to say
that someone is something but they
identify as something else therefore
what do you mean identify as that and so
I think generally although they are very
hesitant and we're seeing why they're
very hesitant to explain what they mean
but I think generally in a vague way
they mean it in an emotional spiritual
kind of way where in some mysterious
sense a person is is is one sex but sort
of has the mind of another sex and so
that's what it means it again it's very
vague and and and and fluid for them it
doesn't I don't think they spend a lot
of time thinking about it it's not
well-formed but that's basically what
they mean when they
talking about identifying as a man or a
woman but doctor GU knows that that he
can't say that
that can't be the definition there is
nothing remotely or scientifically
there's nothing remotely scientific or
medical about that that is religious
that is an almost religious cult-like
concept right this whole idea of a man
trapped in a woman's body or a woman
trapped in a man's body
that is intensely religious it found a
religion I subscribe to but that is
there's no science there one kind of
person trapped in another person's body
now you're getting into things like
souls and spirits and that's the only
way to read that I keep there's no way
to read that in a scientific way so he
says so he can't say that instead he
says that a man is a biological male
with a Y chromosome and male
reproductive organs or anyone who
identifies as having a Y chromosome and
male reproductive organs but how can you
identify as having a certain chromosome
what the hell can that possibly mean and
even if you do identify as having a
chromosome even if a person could
somehow feel like they have a Y
chromosome even though you know I I
don't know what chromosomes feel like so
I don't what what does that what does
that mean but even if they identify as
having it yet they don't have it then
isn't that the end of the discussion you
know sometimes people can think things
that aren't true it happens all the time
it's not a complicated concept people
can think that if something is a certain
way and they're just wrong so that's the
other option here when you say well what
do you mean there are people wait
they're wrong it's that's it we could
talk about why they're wrong we could
talk about to you what's going on
psychologically they think something
that isn't truth if you're telling me oh
well they identify as having a Y
chromosome okay well let's do a test do
they have one no well then they don't
that's it it has no bearing on the
definition but goo says that um being a
man depends on the biological physical
reality of having a certain chromosome
yet if you don't physically have it but
feel like you do then suddenly you do
how does that work does the chromosome
magically materialize in some invisible
and spiritual way just because you feel
like you have one or does the definition
all of a sudden get suspended in your
case because your feelings override it
but if that's the case then haven't you
just gotten rid of the definition
completely aren't you really saying a
man is anyone with male reproductive
organs and a Y chromosome or not isn't
that really what what GU is saying here
a man is this or not that yeah either
way which is another way of saying a man
is anything which is another way of
saying um the word man has no definition
and that at the end of the day is what
they really believe okay it's it's what
they want to say that these words have
no definition now leftist they don't
like definitions definitions are
limiting their objective they they
impose themselves on you you're not able
to make them up as you go along so they
don't like especially from a
relativistic standpoint the the one
thing you hate the most is a definition
so you want to get rid of them but they
can't really say that these words have
no definition because if the word man
doesn't mean anything then it doesn't
mean anything for a woman to identify as
one you see that's the problem if we're
saying that uh well a man is any zip
that's a it's a fluid concept doesn't
really mean it well then what does it
mean for a woman to say she is one that
then that statement has no meaning then
for her to say she's a man is exactly
the same thing as her saying she's a
woman which why are we calling her a man
then what's the whole point of this if
the word man has no meaning then it's
nonsensical for a woman to say that she
is one but if it does have a meaning
then it's also nonsensical for a woman
to say that she is one leftist lose
either way with this and they know it or
the smart one note and smart ones know
it anyway the other problem is if these
words have no definition if they don't
mean anything then identity politics
goes out the window it's a very weird
thing
with left is where on one hand they want
to make everything fluid they want to
put everything on a spectrum they want
to say nothing means anything there are
no definition on the other hand they
want to say they want to emphasize these
differences and these definitions for
the purposes of identity politics so
they can constantly say well you belong
in that group therefore you should think
this and do that you belong in that
group over there so therefore you should
think this and do that so they want to
do both at the same time they want to
put everyone on a spectrum blend
everyone together while at the same time
dividing everyone very harshly very very
in a very you know sort of defined way
and and then make up rules for people's
groups based on that they're trying to
do both and you can't do both so where
are we left well we still have no
definition
dr. goo a doctor could not define the
word man a word that again my
six-year-old could define because his
ideology will not allow it
defining man as a biological male or
anyone who identifies as being a
biological male is exactly like defining
mark zuckerberg as the current CEO of
facebook or anyone who feels like they
are the current CEO of facebook which
means that mark zuckerberg is either
mark zuckerberg or anyone that's what it
means which means that he is no one in
particular that is not a definition that
is an anti definition that is the exact
opposite of a definition so we have a
man which is a certain thing and then we
have people who are not men yet
think they are that's a
separate thing because those people
identifying as a man in order for them
to do so they can only do that if the
word man has a solid objective
definition so whatever they are whatever
would however however we define those
people that definition depends
inherently on the word man having itself
an objective solid non-negotiable
definition but if it does have that sort
of definition then whatever you call
those other people over here you can't
call them men there's something else
you can call them whatever you want call
them trans call them whatever you want
to call them you can call me you just
can't call them a man one last point dr.
GU kept bringing up intersex people kept
saying well as intersex people this is
completely irrelevant and this is a move
you're gonna see from leftists all the
time on this where they say Oh what
about intersex intersex people are
irrelevant to this discussion for two
reasons
number one an intersex person and these
are very rare that you have intersex
people but goose has one point seven
percent it's not that high but even that
is very low so intersex person they do
not prove that biological sex is on a
spectrum they don't prove that an
intersex person is a person whose
biological sex is harder to identify
just by looking this is someone who
externally physically their biological
sex is going to be more ambiguous
because of mutations because something
went wrong this is someone who suffers
from a mutation from a deformity there's
an illness here there's this is a this
is an aberration but that doesn't mean
they don't have a biological sex you
could still you could still determine it
through it through a DNA test you could
still find out what their biological sex
is it's just harder to with with almost
everyone you could tell what they are
just by looking at them with with
intersects with so-called intersex
people it's harder to tell just by
looking and so you might have to
dive deeper as it were second point even
if I were to concede that intersex
people somehow exist on a spectrum and
they're in between man and woman and
they're sort of neither they're a
separate thing
I don't concede that but if I did it
would have nothing it had it has no
bearing at all on trans people because
it a trans man is a biological woman who
says she's a man who identifies as a man
a trans woman is a biological man who
identifies as a woman if it was an
intersex person we wouldn't call them
trans we just say they're intersex so
the trans is a completely separate
category so if we were to establish that
intersex people biologically physically
are you know there's something else
going on with them
that doesn't change anything with trans
people AIDS these two things aren't
related because with a trans person
again that we know biologically we know
what they are
that's not ambiguous so it's just it's a
completely irrelevant point all right
and of course it's a self-defeating
point because when you bring intersex
people into it and you're saying well
yeah look at that I mean biologically
there's some different stuff going on
okay so are you now conceding then that
in order for a person you know to that
you're conceding that the biology does
matter because if it does then that's
going to disqualify the trans people but
if you're saying they don't know well
biology still doesn't matter okay if
that's the case then why are you
bringing up intersex people at all all
right let's we'll get to e miss well
before we get to emails one other thing
quickly you know I don't usually get
into all the apps and who's he wants
it's that the kids use these days but on
their infernal cellular cellular device
contraptions but someone did tell me
about this thing called face app where
you can upload a picture of yourself or
anyone and then you can age it or do
whatever you want to change it and to
try out a bunch of new looks right in a
virtual setting so I did I was bored
last night I did give it a shot and you
know I
I found a look for myself that I'm just
putting it out there because I want to
get your opinion I really honestly I
think I might go with it in real life
but I want to kind of get a feel for the
room here so I'm going to show you this
and you tell me should I go with this
look or not well I look at this here so
there it is
what do you think honestly let's just be
honest here I look amazing in that
picture that's I just do the mustache
with the stubble the long flowing locks
I look like I used to sing for the Bee
Gees but then I got addicted to crack
and so I got kicked out and then
eventually I cleaned myself up and
started writing erotic fiction novels
while working part-time at a Spencer's
gifts in San Diego which is to say it's
a great look and I really I don't know
if I can get my hair to that point where
it would be so magnificent but I can try
anyway alright let's do a few emails
Matt well show at gmail.com Matt well
show at gmail.com this is from Elise
says hi Matt because I volunteer in
children's ministry and youth group at
my church I've been exposed to all
different kinds of schooling including
methods I never knew existed like
unschooling which quote encourages
exploration of activities initiated by
the children themselves believing that
the more personal learning is the more
meaningful well understood and therefore
useful to the child while courses may
occasionally be taken unschooling
questions the usefulness of standard
curricula conventional grading methods
and other features of traditional
schooling she's quoting now from us from
Wikipedia I first thought it was kind of
free-range homeschooling but the more I
learn about it the less similar it seems
I'm not sure what to think about it
while unschooling can equip kids to
handle certain real-life situations
better than their peers I see some of
them falling behind in academic areas
like reading and math it's awesome that
they're able to fully engage in the air
their interests and I often hear that
unschooling allows for kids to learn
things normal school wouldn't give time
to but I question the balance and
apparent lack of structure I also know
kids can learn things not traditionally
taught in school without on schooling do
you have any experience with or thoughts
on unschooling yeah I understand
and the philosophy behind it and I agree
in many ways with the philosophy that a
lot of kids learn better maybe all kids
in some ways learn better in a non
structured environment when they're able
to pursue their own interests and so
it's sort of an unschooling lesson would
be it's like right if we're going on a
hike with my kids in the woods and
they'll just pick up random leaves and
bugs and point out random trees and sort
of ask about them and well as we go
along we'll tell them oh that's what
that is and so we're talking and
learning and walking and we're in nature
and it becomes a kind of lesson in
biology and and and and things like that
so that's on schooling and I think
that's very important for kids and I
also agree that the modern curricula
that you find in public schools are
often counterproductive and and
ineffective and I think even harmful to
some kids which is why a lot of kids
have to be drugged basically have to be
have to be sedated with drugs in order
to sit there and read just regurgitate
the information that they're told that's
what most curricula consist of these
days so I agree with all that but I also
do think that kids need a more
structured environment to learn as well
I I think that the unschooling thing
sets up a false dichotomy where it's
like we have to choose between well do
they learn in an unstructured way or do
they learn in a structured way well kids
they can do both you have the structured
school setting and I'm all about home
schooling I think home schooling is
great that's what we do for our kids but
that's a structured environment there's
an actual curriculum that you follow it
also though they are they're also being
unschooled all the time I mean
constantly if you have young kids or
always asking questions they're very
curious they're exploring and so you do
that too so that's my point I think I
think unschooling is great but
there's no reason why it has to replace
a structured academic environment which
I think kids also need and will benefit
from as long as it's structured in the
right way so if we point if we observe
that that school is often structured
wrongly I don't think the correct
response is well it shouldn't be
structured at all it's like if you're in
a building and it was you notice that
the structure is wrong it was built the
wrong way well that's a that's a good
argument for repairing it for rebuilding
it even but that's not an argument for
getting rid of buildings completely all
right this is from Tony says hey Matt
loved the show on last Thursday show you
discussed public shaming in relation to
the gentleman at the bagel shop that was
mocked for his height you brought up
good and bad public shaming and the
prospect of someone who is or may be
mentally unstable or having issues
subsequently committing suicide after
being publicly shamed a recent example
of this that has gone rather unnoticed
might fit your theory a 70 year old
runner committed suicide days after
being disqualified for the LA Marathon
after a series of articles were written
detailing that he cheated while running
the race he posed he posted the fastest
time in the LA Marathon history for his
age group marathon investigation
researched and investigated his result
determined he cheated and he was
subsequently disqualified he remained
defiant in defending allegation only
only to commit suicide days later the
articles accusing him cheating were
published online and posted on various
social media and were of course met with
all sorts of comments criticism and
public shaming I'm interested to hear
your take on this does this fall under
the category of good public shaming or
bad public shaming have we come too far
when it comes to social media and public
shaming I'm also happy to discuss this
with you in more detail so yeah I do
think as I said that we have come too
far in many ways with public shaming or
maybe not too far just we've gone in the
wrong direction where we publicly shame
people who don't need it and where it's
not appropriate so a guy who has a
essentially a mental breakdown I don't
think it needs to be publicly shamed for
that now this person I'm not familiar
with this case at all I don't know
anything about it but if somebody and I
don't even know if he really did cheat
but if someone did cheat or something
and they and they're guilty of that and
then that information is reported and
they tragically commit suicide later no
I don't think I wouldn't even call that
public shaming if you do something like
cheat on a major marathon it's going to
make the news it say that it is a
newsworthy event especially if you're an
older person and you know if if you made
the news by winning and then it turns
out you cheated then that is also going
to make the news that's completely
normal and justified and then if that
person goes to commit suicide I think
that's someone who it's a tragic thing
that's someone who feels ashamed of what
they did if he did in fact do it and you
know those all kinds of things that go
into it and I would also say that if
you're 70 years old and cheating on a
marathon you're probably already
troubled it's not a normal thing to do
so I would say that's what led to the
suicide it's not public shaming so again
if you if you do something bad which is
newsworthy and not all bad things or
newsworthy but if you do something
that's bad that is newsworthy and it's
reported by the news and then you feel
deeply ashamed I that's I don't think
that's even I wouldn't even qualify that
as public shaming that is simply a
natural consequence of the thing you did
alright um well so we got here I guess
well a couple other emails that would be
long answer so I think we'll leave it
there and we'll talk again tomorrow
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
Planned Parenthood made the difficult
and personal decision yesterday to
terminate their president after just 10
months or a little over three trimesters
in the position it is unclear whether
Planned Parenthood used chemicals or
forceps to evacuate President lianna Wu
from her office we will examine what the
firing means for the modern left then
Bill Whittle stops by to talk about the
50th anniversary of the Apollo 11 moon
landing all that and more check it out
on the Michael
show